welcome to the mcu welcome to the
universe
tell me where were you before getting
involved how much did you know
of the characters of the stories i have
to confess i'm not an
expert so i was you know i had a lot of
catching up to do
in terms of the mcu i was obviously
hugely aware of it in popular culture
but i wasn't a mega fan
so i have learned a lot you know in the
last year or so
and it's been fascinating because
obviously the tva
and what we explore in loki is a
completely different facet of the mcu so
in a way that was kind of
good for me because it was sort of a
fresh area um
you know that has not been seen on on
film or on screen before so
um so that's been really exciting and
then you know my character obviously
as ravonna renslayer and as a judge and
you know as part of this world it's
somewhat of an origin story for her
um in the mcu so so that was kind of
nice to be
feeling like i'm starting at the very
beginning for her you really believe in
this low-key variant
luckily he believes in himself enough
for the both of us
is it as hardcore as everybody says it
is once you get inside it's like this
secret little group of everybody's got
stories and story lines but nobody's
allowed to say anything is it really
that hardcore
i don't know i mean it's you know for me
it's
it's also you know a group of amazing
actors you know working together to tell
a story and i think you know being able
to work with
owen wilson and tom hiddleston and women
with sarco you know that though
us us three were actually all at the
same drama school
um at different times so so that was
kind of nice and i think
as much as there is the big world of the
mcu and the fans and
and and all of the sort of expectation
and excitement you know
when you're on the set you know you're
you're a group of actors and you're
playing and you're having a great time
and you're
sort of trying to press each other's
buttons and you know you're fighting and
it and it's just the best kind of
playful environment
do you get brownie points with anybody
in your life kiddos or
adults for being part of this show
right i mean i have a six-year-old and
he's freaking out that he's not in here
talking to you guys right now
like who gives you the points major
brownie points from my friend's son
ray who's seven um and he is
obsessed and um yeah he's telling me
about the mcu i mean i'm guess getting
like my backstory and
and history from rey so um so yeah i'm
really excited for him to see it i've
suddenly become really much cooler in
his eyes
you have to put like a little credit in
parentheses under your name in the
credits that says like character
development by rey
he's totally helping special
consultation yeah exactly
tell me a little bit about working with
the god of mischief
like how crazy is it gonna get for you
and your character does he drag you in
any places maybe you don't want to go
well i couldn't possibly spoil the
journey but um
but no i mean certainly in the early
scenes you know it was really fun to
have our courtroom scene the first scene
that i have with tom
as loki you know and as judge ren slayer
you know just being there kind of trying
to
you know put putting him on trial
essentially for crimes against the
sacred timeline and
you know this is a character that's not
used to bowing down to authority
or um and my character's not used to
being questioned
or you know teased and so
so that was a really fun dynamic and you
know we get to go
to some really interesting places and
the the development of um
the dynamic between my character and
owen wilson's character is also really
fun
for those people who don't know about
the universe and don't know
about how amazing loki is give me
something
what can they expect draw us in well
there's
intrigue there's action um
there's you know an amazingly sort of
quirky funny
sense of humor to the show i think
that's going to be really exciting for
people as well it's done with a light
touch
but it's also this epic adventure you
know there's sort of thriller aspects to
it of
um this sort of mystery and obviously
you've got tom hiddleston you've got
owen wilson you've got wilmie masako you
know you've got sofia dimartino you've
got this amazing cast and
um i'm really excited for everyone to
see
you know see it all come together but
it's really exciting